Lucy is with us in California
hi Lucy welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi Dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up I'm I found out about a
month ago my husband committed financial
infidelity to the tune of $200,000 which
is about what we make a year and we're
going to FPU we're on baby step to
putting the dog on Craigslist and the
cat on eBay but I still think we don't
have that unity and I think it's coming
from I don't think he's buying in into
the problems this has caused and where I
am emotionally and John where's Joey we
have four other issues and it didn't
work because what I felt was happening
was the counselor was being used by him
to vilify me so I feel stuck when you do
another counselor because you know
what's happened here's you've got a
breach of trust and he doesn't
understand how deeply you're wounded by
that breach of trust yep it Act the
reason we call it financial infidelity
in our world is because it activates the
same trust button that sexual infidelity
activates in a different way but I mean
it's basically you are a liar how can I
trust you again
that's the that's what it that's the
button it pushes right and so how does
he regain that trust well number one
it's going to take some time
number two it's going to take a lot of
communication and number three it's
going to take unbelievable consistency
on his part to where he becomes worthy
of trust after lying to you to the tune
of 200 grand yes
and that problem if he's not if he's not
getting that that is not a money problem
that's a marriage problem and you need
to see a marriage coach and the two of
you you know call that out and deal with
that okay
okay and so I mean I don't I mean I
think that's the front
I would attack this battle on in other
words I wouldn't it's not a budgeting
technique thing okay he if you are if
you do something wrong and you feel
badly for having done that wrong thing
you prove it by changing right yeah and
what you're saying is he's not really
doing that part of it so it makes you
think he's not really sorry
exactly yep that's how that's all mine
now that's how it feels and that's you
know you know if someone says oh I'm
sorry I stole your wallet and while
they're reaching into your purse and
stealing it again you know that's you
they're not sorry
they're still doing it and so I'm sorry
I got drunk and well you're drunk again
you know and you weren't that sorry
about it and so you know that that's
what repentance is what we call it
Christianity repentance is to turn away
from doing stupid stuff right and so and
he's not turned did you catch him or did
he come clean I was looking at the
numbers I will admit me we're doing
Davis and numbers weren't tying up and I
finally asked and he finally admitted it
okay so why was he hiding it because he
was ashamed or because he was just being
deceitful it it was I think from a shame
standpoint like the money was used to
take care of things for the family so it
wasn't like you know gambling or
anything like that like I he just well
he was ashamed that he wasn't in control
with the money and wasn't able to give
you guys everything that he thought you
should have yeah and so he hid it and
did it anyway yeah okay well that's not
as bad as other options you're right but
it is still a breach of trust and he
still has to get that the way this has
made you feel even though he was quote
doing it for you
unquote right exactly
it's still lying it's still deception
and it still requires that some
effort is made over a period of time
with consistency to regain trust to be
worthy of trust again trust worthy and
that's the deal so hey thank you for the
call open phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five you jump in
we'll talk about your life and your
money this is what we do here so it is
vital if you want to win with money and
you're married that both of you are
involved in the handling of the money
both of you know everything that's going
on every thing that's going on if you
think it's cute to lie to your husband
and hide your target bags under the bed
that's not cute that's lying and you're
not only cutting the throat of your
relationship you're pretty much ensuring
that your family's not going to prosper
because all of our data points of all
the families that prosper and become
millionaires show that the couples in
marriage situations are working together
open communication pulling in the
russain direction it's absolutely vital